la liberté d'expression ce n'est pas
simplement dire des choses qui sont
vraies qui sont intelligentes qui sont
sympathiques et qui sont roses la
liberté d'expression s'il signifie quoi
que ce soit doit peu porteuse le droit
et la possibilité d'exprimer des propos
qui sont offensants haut et odieux la
liberté d'expression ce n'est pas aussi
cela c'est d'abord et avant tout cela
parce que dire des choses qui sont très
gentil pour tout le monde ça on n'a pas
besoin de la liberté d'expression ça
c'est possible même dans le pire des
états totalitaires la liberté
d'expression elles se mesurent riel se
vit lorsque l'on a la possibilité de
proférer comme charlie hebdo dans une
thématique particulière et dans d'autres
thématiques honnête c'est là des propos
qui sont effectivement aux dieux ou
offensant pour une partie de la
population
rappelons nous que en occident en tout
cas et en europe en particulier la
liberté d'expression c'est en grande
partie construite avec la possibilité de
ridiculiser et de tenir des propos
désagréables ans monte offensants à
l'égard de la religion catholique
revenir sur ce type de possibilités
serait évidemment une régression de
civilisation et dire qu'il ne faut pas
offenser le problème c'est que encore
une fois quand on met le doigt dans ce
type dont grenat dire par exemple que la
liberté d'expression doit s'arrêter à
l'eau france qui se fait à autrui ou
certaines communautés
mais tout est offensant le nôtre débat
ils peuvent ensemble pour certains
tenant delà de la religion à 100% tout
est offensant il ya toujours un segment
dans la population qui sera en français
par les propos qui sont tenus par un
autre segment donc dès lors que l'on
rentre dans cet engrenage
il n'y a plus de logique qui permet de
ceux de se prémunir d'une réduction a
finalement très peu de choses de la
liberté d'expression qu'il n'y a pas de
vrai débat public sans liberté
d'expression il n'y a pas de vrai débat
scientifique sur liberté d'expression il
n'y a pas finalement de science sans
liberté d'expression il n'y a pas de
possibilité de création artistique
s'il n'ya pas d'abord une manière de
liberté d'expression
[Musique]